single wohnung mit ausblick heißt es in
der anzeige
mehr als 20 mietinteressenten sind
gekommen um eine kleine hinterhof
wohnung zu besichtigen joana ist einer
von bieten schon seit monaten sucht er
nach einer neuen bleibe und wird auch
diesmal wieder enttäuscht der vermieter
verlangt 565 euro waren für die
einzimmerwohnung und jede menge
gehaltsnachweise und bonitätsauskünfte
vor allem unverschämt teuer
der außendienstmitarbeiter fährt einen
dienstwagen und ist fest angestellt
trotzdem muss er in einer gartenlaube
leben meiner besten freundin in berlin
meinte kann doch das wird alles gut
fasst hier alles und bin sowieso alle
zwei tage ganz werden durch den kanzler
damen einen tag habe ich gesagt ja okay
gut machst du doch nun wird es herbst
und eine heizung hat die gartenlaube
nicht also sucht der 27 jährige weiter
durchforstet täglich wohnungs inserate
besichtigt und bewirbt sich kassiert
immer wieder absagen und ärgert sich
über dreiste vermieter die die lage in
berlin ausnutzen
eigentümer der hat dort laminat verlegt
und die wände gestrichen wenn kaum mit
rechnung mit quittungen inoffiziell
heute davon hier knapp 3000 euro auf die
hand haben nur weil er seinem laminat
verlegt hat zudem habe ich noch gesagt
ich bin zwar verzeichnete aber blöd bin
ich nicht juana gibt nicht auf vor
verzweiflung hatte auch schon einen
kleinanzeigen inserat geschaltet um sich
als seriöser mieter anzupreisen
doch es meldet sich niemand die kunden
von jennifer sager haben es da leichter
es sind meist führungskräfte
ausländischer firmen die nach berlin
ziehen sagers relocation firma sucht
ihnen exklusiv passende wohnungen heraus
und kümmert sich um alle nötigen
unterlagen dass die lage am
wohnungsmarkt angespannt ist merkt auch
die relocation maklerin den kundenkreis
hat sich in den letzten fünf jahren
verändert das sind viele deutsche dazu
gekommen die einfach aus dem
bundesgebiet hierher ziehen oder auch
deutsche die vielleicht eine weile im
ausland fahren und zurückkommen und die
einfach selber schon angefangen hat zu
gucken und einfach feststellen sie
kriegen keine rückmeldung und deswegen
engagieren die gerne jemanden der diesen
job und so muss man es heutzutage machen
versilbern nimmt mindestens eine million
wohnungen viel in deutschland weit
besonders in großstädten wie berlin
hinzu kommt dass die hauptstadt
bevölkerung jedes jahr um rund 40.000
menschen an wächst der neubau von
wohnungen kommt da nicht hinterher
berlin kreuzberg eine besonders beliebte
wohngegend die mieten haben sich hier in
den vergangenen zehn jahren verdoppelt
trotzdem wollen dutzende interessenten
eine überteuerte hinterhof wohnung
besichtigen
viele suchen schon sehr lange und sind
frustriert
50 leute und ganz schlechte wohnung
immer nur frustration
überall wo man hingeht dieselben leute
es kann sein dass ganze wohnungssuche
abgase und keine ahnung eltern will man
nicht mehr ziehen aber seine sachen
einkaufen müssen
auch juan ochoa musste einiges in kauf
nehmen nach intensiver suche hatte aber
doch noch eine bleibe gefunden altbau
zentral gelegen und mit zwei großen
zimmern und balkon
einziger haken die wohnung kostet mehr
als 1000 euro warm
nach der skg prof mieten zahlen die das
eigene budget deutlich übersteigen
für viele wohnungssuchende in
großstädten ist das der einzige weg ein
dach über dem kopf zu finden